hello everyone and welcome to khan
academy live sat class my name is eric
lee i'm an sat tutor and one of the sat
experts here at khan academy i'm so
excited to be joining you today and over
the course of the next three weeks as we
practice and prepare for the sat
before we jump into sat math which is
the topic for today i want to give you a
sneak peek at what's coming ahead over
the course of the next three weeks let's
take a look so
today like i said we'll be covering sat
math but
next thursday i'll walk us through some
sat reading topics and the following
thursday we'll cover s.a.t writing now
each of these classes is going to take
place thursday nights at 7 pm eastern 4
pm pacific and we're covering a
different topic each time so make sure
to tune in
now if you can't make any of these
classes don't worry because we'll record
all of the classes and send them out to
everyone afterwards so you can review it
whenever you want
so i'm super excited to be going through
this and for today
we're going to
focus on math like i mentioned so what's
the plan for the day well the first 25
minutes of today i'm going to walk
through how to avoid careless mistakes
in the sat math section
next i'll i'll show you how to approach
function notation problems which are a
common concept tested in the sat math
section
then in the next 25 minutes you'll get a
chance to practice what you've learned
on khan academy
and while you're practicing we'll have
khan academy and college board staff on
standby who can chat with you one on one
about and answer any question you have
about sat math reading writing or
anything sat related
you'll want to make sure to practice
during this time though because these
staff members are only going to be on
until the end of the hour
then in the last 10 minutes of class
i'll answer a few questions discuss
homework in the plan for the next class
and then you'll get your badge for
completing the class but remember you
have to stay to the very end of the
class to get that batch so that's the
plan for the next three weeks and what
we're going to cover today and i'm so
excited to get started with sat math and
to help you practice and prepare for
your upcoming test let's jump in
so why are we talking about careless
mistakes well let me know if any of
these questions uh sound familiar to you
so have you ever solved uh for the wrong
variable in an sat math question
or maybe you missed a question because
your final answer was in the wrong units
or maybe you were working through a
problem and you step stopped one step
short of the right answer you were
almost there but not quite or maybe you
went one step too far
or maybe you made a simple addition or
subtraction error or this one is
probably the most annoying to me
maybe you even got the right answer
but then you didn't transfer the right
answer to the answer sheet
well all of these types of mistakes are
perfectly common human mistakes that
anyone can make but what i'm going to
show you today is a process that's
really helped me
and helps other students reduce the
number of careless mistakes they make
there are other ways to to go about it
but this is one process that's worked
really well for me
so let's take a look so there are really
four steps that i'd recommend you take
to cut down on careless mistakes
so the first one is just to read and
understand the question in any charts or
tables that you have now this is both
the question and any charts or tables so
don't
move on until you really understand
everything and one thing you can do here
is underline as you go sentence by
sentence to break down the question
rather than trying to take it all in at
once
the next thing i'd recommend is that you
think through the steps you need to take
to solve the problem so this is thing
this includes things like figuring out
which variable you're solving for so x
or y
this is thinking about what units your
final answer needs to be in
and any operations that you need to do
to get to the right
answer
once you know what steps you're going to
follow
you can then start actually doing the
math and so i would do this on paper or
in the calculator and i'd really
discourage you from doing the math in
your head because no matter how
confident you you might feel about the
problem the moment you're doing mental
you start doing more mental calculations
you really up your chances of making a
careless mistake
now the last and final step that i'd
suggest you take is to mark down the
answer in your test booklet before
bubbling it in so say our answer was b
64.
um then
i recommend you circle it or you write
it and you box it so that when you're
transferring answers for for this
problem to the answer sheet
you have no doubt in the world that your
answer is b and the right answer makes
it over there so to recap
you're going to want to read and
understand the question and any charts
or tables
think through the steps you need to take
to solve the problem
do the math on paper or in your
calculator and then mark down the answer
in your test booklet before bubbling it
in so
this this is a process that we're going
to now apply when it uh to real sat math
questions and
let's take a look at what this looks
like the first question will be
will be more straightforward and then
we'll see how this applies to more
complex questions as we go
so let's take a look at this first
question
so first step is to read and understand
the problem so during a timed test
alexander typed
742 words in 14 minutes okay 742 words
in 14 minutes that seems worth
underlining
assuming alexander works at this rate
for the next hour which of the following
best approximates the number of words he
would type in that hour
okay so i have some information and for
me it's helpful to write down
the information i have since it just
helps me better understand it and so we
have 742 words in one in 14 minutes and
then the question
is how many words would alexander type
in one hour so in this case it's
60 minutes
okay so i understand the question and
the information that's been given to me
and the next thing i want to do is think
through the process i want to follow to
solve this question so i think the first
thing i could do is figure out how many
words per one minute
per one minute
and then because the question is asking
me how many words would he type in one
hour the second thing i can do is
multiply by
60. so that seems like a good process
and will get me all the way to the final
answer so now i can actually start doing
the math
so to calculate words per one minute i
can just do 742 words
divided by
14 minutes
and i'll pull up my calculator and the
real thing you won't have this
digital calculator you'll have your own
but just bear with me here
and so here i have 53 words and so
that's 53 words per 1 minute
words
per 1
minute but i'm not done yet right so the
second step here is to multiply by 60
minutes
and the interesting thing you'll notice
here is once i multiply by the 60
minutes i've actually got a minutes
factor in the numerator and a minutes
in the denominator and so any unit
divided by itself is just going to be 1
so that would go away
and then if i do this math of 53 times
60
let's do that multiply this by 60
we get the final answer of
3180 and then last step is to box that
answer or write c so that there's no
chance of me
missing uh miss bubbling
so one thing the last thing i want to
show you here is
what the process does in questions like
this so because we knew that we needed
to solve first for the words per minute
and then multiply by 60 it meant that
some of these other answers were less
tempting so while
while we got 53 words here and while it
was an answer choice we knew that that
wasn't the right final answer because we
hadn't taken the second step here of
multiplying by 60 minutes to get to the
hour hopefully this shows you how to
apply this process with a question that
has a few steps in it and you're dealing
with some units
but let's see how this question how this
process stacks up when we apply it to a
different kind of question different set
different scenario so in this next
question let's give it a read geometry
students participated in an activity to
classify the shapes in the room by
number of sides and color okay the table
above displays the results and then if a
triangle is chosen at random
what is the probability that it is blue
okay so
we're classifying shapes and we have
we want to understand the probability uh
that if a triangle is chosen at random
what's the probability that it is blue
so before i move on from here uh just
because i understand the question
doesn't mean i'm ready to actually start
solving it yet because in this case we
have this table here that we want to
tackle first
so let's take a look and make sure we
understand the table before we go any
further so we've got shapes on the left
hand side we've got these colors here of
red and blue and then these total
columns so total
this this total column on the right hand
side it seems seems to be the number of
shapes
and then this one on the bottom this
total column is a number of shapes that
are by color and this one is shapes by
type okay
okay so now i understand the question i
understand
the table and now i can start to think
about how i would solve this
so let's read that question again if a
triangle is chosen at random from this
activity what is the probability that it
is blue so that to me says that i'm
going to be focusing here on
just the triangles because
it says if a triangle is chosen at
random so i'm not worrying about these
quadrilaterals or the pentagons or the
others
and then it's asking me what is the
probability that it is blue well i've
got the blue
triangles here and so there are three
blue triangles and
uh probability is always how many
chances of getting something out of the
total number of chances and so that
total number of triangles then is here
and you've got three out of four now
what i want to point out here is
in this problem understanding the table
was crucial because
you'll notice if you look at some of the
other answer choices
the totals that you have
in the rest of the table
are also present here and if you didn't
take your time to understand the table
it might have been tempting to to use
some of these other variables that you
see in the table like the 16 the 8
or even this one as well
but if you follow an organized process
then that's how you
can cut down on these kinds of mistakes
so
we've done now a question with units and
a few steps in the process we've done a
question now
with a chart that you've been presented
now let's take a look at what happens
with a problem that has a few steps in
it and you don't have a diagram
drawn for you or a chart presented to
you this time let's take a look so let's
uh give this problem a read
cara is hanging a poster that is 91
centimeters wide
in her room okay
the center of the wall is 180
centimeters from the right end of the
wall okay
if cara hangs the poster so that the
center of the poster is located
at the center of the wall
how far will the left and right edges of
the poster be
from the right end of the wall
okay so
a little bit more information to work
with this time right
but this is where breaking down the
problem piece by piece and drawing a
diagram as you go can really be helpful
so let's take a read cara is hanging a
poster it's 91 centimeters so i've got
my beautiful poster excuse my inability
to draw straight lines
so this is my poster
and we've got a 91 centimeters here
and then i've got a wall that i'm
hanging this inside of so if i draw this
wall
and it says the center of the wall is
180 centimeters from the right end of
the wall
so then i'm just going to estimate the
center's got to be about there and so if
this is the center
the center is 180 centimeters from the
right so we've got 180 centimeters
and then
i have this diagram and now i'm putting
the poster so that the center of the
poster is located at the center of the
wall
so then i'm going to move that poster
inside here
oh and then this again is 91 centimeters
and now what is the question now now i i
have this diagram that can help me solve
the solve the problem the question is
how far will the left and right edges of
the poster be from the right end of the
wall okay so i've got this right end of
the wall
and i want to know
this distance so the left edge of the
poster to the right end of the wall and
then the right edge of the poster to the
right end of the wall
and i can label this one l
and then i'll just change colors here
this one i'll label r
so now that i have the diagram it really
helps to clarify what i'm dealing with
and what i'm solving for so let's take
these one by one so if i want to solve
for this distance of l from the left
edge of the poster to the right wall
it looks like this 180 centimeters here
is a pretty good starting point so if i
it's at least 180 centimeters since i'm
all the way to the center and then i
have this half of the poster that is
just to the left of the wall and because
i know that this 90 this poster is 91
centimeters wide
i can add 91 divided by two
and so then this
should get me the value of l and so if i
do
open up this calculator i've got 180
plus
91 divided by 2
and that'll get me
225.5 225.5
centimeters and now i want to go to the
right edge
and i think i can use this 180
centimeters again as a reference point
since i know that poster is right in the
middle right so
we've got 180 centimeters
and then this time this this
this half of the poster is actually
closer to the right edge of the wall
than this one and so instead of adding
something it looks like we'll have to
subtract and again since i know that
this is 91 centimeters total
i can subtract 91 divided by 2
and then pull up that calculator again
180
minus 91
by 2
gets me 134.5
centimeters
so then i want to look at my answer
choices now and i've got the left edge
at 225 225.5 okay well that one's out
and that one's out and then the right
edge should be 134.5
and so then my final answer again
is
c
so in this problem it was very important
to
work through the the information given
to you step by step and to draw a
diagram to help you work through it
piece by piece because if you had done
the simpler i tried to skip through and
do it mentally you might have done 180
minus 91 or plus 91 and you would have
missed some of the some of the nuances
in this problem but once you draw the
diagram it becomes a lot easier to to
work through
so
we've now
done a handful of
problems to show you how you can use
this process to really reduce your
chances of making careless mistakes and
now i want to move us on to tackling
function notation problems so
let's keep going and let's take a look
so function notation before i actually
start
start doing practice problems here i
just want to walk you through
a quick review of function notation so
what is a function first well a function
a
function
is a mathematical expression that takes
in one or more inputs
inputs and generates only one
output one output
and that's really key though
having one or more inputs but all of
those only ever generating one unique
output is what really sets a function
apart
now a few ways you might see functions
notated in
the sat is with something like f of x
or maybe
h of x
or
you might see a composition of functions
where you have f of h
of x
and this is also equivalent to
this f of h
of x these two expressions are
the same thing just a different kind of
notation
now
let's say for example f of x equals x
plus one another way you might see
functions show up is in a table format
so in this case you have this nice table
here of f of x and f of x and for given
values of x
given this definition of f of x you'd
have certain values of f of x so this is
one way you might see it and then the
last way
you might see a function show up is
graphically so here we have a graph
where there's x and there's f of x
and
for example there's one two three
and you've got one two three
for certain values of x
you would you might have corresponding
values of f of x or y
and so
with a chart like this you can really
trace on the x-axis and then go up
and see what the corresponding y value
or f of x value is
at that value of x
so these are really
this really covers a lot of the
different ways that function notation
can show up in the sat but you haven't
seen a practice problem yet and so let's
now apply what we've seen here to see it
in action
so let's take a look take a look here
just because we're no longer focusing
exclusively on careless mistakes doesn't
mean we're we're changing our process
though so same process as before
consider the table shown above what is
the value of f of f of 4 okay so i've
got that as the question and then i have
a table here so for given values of x
then i have corresponding values of f of
x
and so we've got f of f of 4. so when
you have a question a function notation
question like this the key thing to
remember is that you want to work from
the inside
out
now what do i mean by that i mean that
the first thing you want to solve for is
this f of 4
and then you can worry about the f of
f
let me just rewrite that then you can
worry about the f
oop
there she's f of f of 4.
and so if i solve first for f of 4 it's
really asking me what is the value of f
of x when x is 4 here so if i've got use
the table i've got 4 and the
corresponding value of f of x is 0.
so then this 0 i can substitute into
here and then this expression
simplifies to just f of 0. then i can
return to the table
and for that value when x is 0
f of x is 2.
so i've got two
i box the right answer i'm realizing now
all of the
answers to these sample problems seem to
be c
um
promised that was not on purpose uh but
let's keep going and see what this looks
like when the table's a bit more
complicated or there are a few more a
few more pieces of information to work
with okay consider the table shown at
left what is the value of g of f of
negative one okay so for me i prefer to
see this as g of f of negative one
that's just
easier for me to understand and so it's
always okay to rewrite a problem so that
it's uh or rephrase it so that it's
easier for you to understand so again
this is similar to the last one and i
want to work from inside
out
but let me make sure i understand the
table first so this time i've got given
values of x here
and then i've got f of x
and then i've got g of x up here okay so
i want to solve then
inside
and then outside
and so
f of negative 1 then so for
let's go to the table when x is negative
1 what is the value of f of x so it
looks like we're right there we've got 2
and then we can plug this in similar to
the last problem
and solve and simplify this to say g of
2. and in this case we return to the
table we're looking at 2
and then
this time i'm looking at g of x so then
i'm looking over here at
4.
so this is another example of function
notation just with a different
way of expressing it
and now we'll do one final function
notation problem this time with a graph
so let's keep moving
so what is the approximate value of g of
f of five so
that one makes sense to me and then on
this left hand side i have the graphs of
the function of f and function g shown
below
so here's f here's g
and then for certain values of x here
the y values of f and g are shown
and okay so i think i understand that
now again i want to solve inside out so
f of 5 and then i've got g of f of 5.
and what we can do here is
we'll now have to reference the chart
here so when x is 5
to solve for f of 5 what is the value of
f so what i can do is trace up through
here
and it looks like i'm intersecting f
here at nine
and so then the value of f when x is
five is going to be nine
and i can substitute that into here
and this becomes g of nine
and then i can look at the table here so
when x is nine
i'm here i can trace up and this time
i'm looking at x
and it looks like i'm intersecting here
at seven
so then this value is seven
i mark down seven
and you're good to go
so
now you've seen a few ways to
reduce the chances of making careless
mistakes on the sat you've seen a few
different flavors of that with a few
different problems and you've also seen
a few different examples of function
notation problems so now uh it was
probably easier to follow along
as i was working through it but to see
if you've understood it it's now your
turn to practice what you've learned so
head to khan academy.org sat the link is
also in the event description and head
over there and join me as i head over
there and to practice what you've
learned
now
for the next 30 for the next about 25-30
minutes khan academy and college board
experts are available on standby to chat
with you one on one and there will just
be a little box in the bottom right of
khan academy where you can click ask us
a question and send us any sat related
question you have then at 6 50 eastern 4
50 pacific come back here join me here
i'll wrap up answer any questions you
might have and then i'll share a badge
i'll share the badge that you earned by
completing
this class so
head on over
i'll head over there too and then i'll
see you in just a bit